what's up my fellow Geeks we are back
for another epic unboxing this time we
have the PlayStation 5 Marvel's
Spider-Man 2 limited edition bundle man
that was a mouthful anyway we are so
excited because we can't wait to play
the game and it is set to release on the
20th of October but in the meantime we
managed to snag ourselves an early set
of the limited edition bundle and we're
gonna unbox it today the best part is
that you can get this limited edition
bundle for 949 Singapore dollars or if
you just fancy the controller that goes
for 114 Singapore dollars and you can
get all of them right now
so with that out of the way let's take a
look at the Box
now the first thing you'll probably know
is that we have Mouse Morales and Peter
Parker but Peter Parker does have the
Symbiote on his arms and he's shooting
out black Symbiote web you also get a
glimpse of the controller and the
console covers which I'm very excited to
see in in this actual form
and you have the Spidey logo on top of
that just an awesome background image of
the two spideys
um you know having a battle with uh
Venom over here which is which is pretty
gnarly I'm so excited and not to mention
this game does support 8K TVs as well as
4K 120 hertz so
I can't wait
oh it just looks like that
and just lift the lid PS5 charging cable
we have oh
the first thing is you guys ready you
guys ready
so cool man
just check out this it's just a nice
gradient from black to Red over here
this is the limited edition dual says
controller actually let me get one of
our default controllers to check it out
so design wise you guys are pretty much
getting the same design language on both
uh controllers whether you have the
default or the Spider-Man not much has
changed but clearly you can see that we
have the Spidey logo on the touchpad
here and you can see like the same bio
just trying to engulf and take over
whatever some spiders suit not sure
which part of Spidey but then again oh
all right so Xenia over here said that
the white kind of uh kind of represents
uh spidey's white eyes so yeah fast
flaps and just looking at the back just
you're playing kind of semi-gloss black
over here so very nice very nice design
though I I wish because you know we have
venom in this maybe we could have put
Venom on this side just saying I think
would have been a nice attached but
overall
really liking this really rocking the
same bio designs only yeah and just for
fun we're going to show you guys limited
edition versus limited edition so we
have the Spider-Man 2 controller here
and we also have the God of War Ragnarok
limited edition controller so which one
do you prefer let us know down in the
comments below with that said let's move
on to the other things what we have all
right so we have the PlayStation 5 stand
as well
nothing special going on here though
they could have done something with it
who knows uh HDMI 2.1 cable as well so
it's gonna come in very handy we're
running out of cables in the office
and hidden underneath as well is a USB a
to USB C cable as well there we go to
charge your controller of course
are you guys ready yeah let's go three
two one
yo I can't see you guys
I need to take a look at myself oh look
at that oh check that out
yo
yo that looks so red
anyway before I continue with my thumb
investigation of this Marvel Spider-Man
limited edition let's take a moment to
talk about today's sponsor
here geek culture we've tested plenty of
chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of four men function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
alright welcome back so let's continue
talking about the PlayStation 5 console
over here now you are getting the kind
of like the same design theme as the
controller as well but I do have to say
the controller is in a darker red so you
do have a little bit of a color
inconsistency here you might be
particular you might not be particular
but you know it might be a little bit
hard to see on camera but uh if anybody
has this as well do uh verify with me in
the comments below so just to run some
math over here we are looking at the
bundle at 949 Singapore dollars and if
you really think about it you guys are
getting a pretty good deal because the
stat end it PlayStation 5 this version
it costs around 799 Singapore dollars
plus the game which costs another 97 it
adds up to about
896. they're about
so if you really compare prices you're
just paying 50 extra for you know a very
nice reskin so when I say it's worth it
of course it's working Spider-Man this
is why you're getting it in the first
place so I'll just really leave it up to
you guys if you already own a PS5 it's
not really considered an upgrade but if
you really do want to own a copy because
Spiderman then sure if you are looking
for a PlayStation 5 in the first place
and you're looking for something a
little bit different or even as a gift
then this is
really well time because you're getting
the console earlier and then you get to
play the game black in October so it
works out anyway so all in all I think
it's a damn good deal alright so we're
gonna wrap up this video right here if
you guys enjoyed watching this then do
like and hit that subscribe button it
really means a lot to us on top of that
we've got more unboxings and more
limited edition videos right here in
fact if you guys enjoy armor car 6 then
check out our collect this Edition
Unboxing right yeah I'm a cool baby
I don't know